[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara
guten abend und willkommen zum
nachrichtenüberblick an diesem montag
die vom sport hat nochmals jemand ein
stück von mir und das sind einige
unserer themen
die zeit wird knapp eine woche noch
wollen die taliban bei den evakuierungen
in kabul zu sehen drohen aber mit
konsequenzen sollte es länger dauern
ab heute gilt 3g nur wer geimpft
getestet oder genesen ist darf noch zum
friseur in gaststätten oder etwa ins
kino
und
es läuft drei wochen nach seinem olympia
gold gewinnt alexander zverev auch in
cincinatti und klettert auf
weltranglisten platz vier
den ausreisewilligen in kabul läuft die
zeit weg eigentlich wollten die usa die
evakuierungen in einer woche beenden
doch das reicht nicht um alle
rauszuholen eine verlängerung lehnen die
taliban ab außenminister maß sagt die
situation am und um den flughafen sei in
den vergangenen stunden noch chaotischer
geworden die menschen sollten sich nicht
auf eigene faust auf den weg dorthin
machen tim krüger
die lage am flughafen in der
afghanischen hauptstadt kabul bleibt
angespannt die bundeswehr meldet das ist
heute morgen um kurz nach 4 uhr am
nordtor ein feuergefecht zwischen
afghanischen sicherheitskräften und
unbekannten angreifern gegeben habe
deutsche und amerikanische soldaten
waren an dem gefecht beteiligt
nachdem die untersuchung vor ort
stattgefunden hat blieb leider zu
beklagen dass ein afghanischer
gestorben ist er sich dort in der
sicherung gefunden hat drei verletzte
wurden verzeichnet auf us-amerikanischer
und auf deutscher seite gab es keine
verletzten das zeigt einmal mehr wie
schwierig die evakuierung von
staatsbürgern und orts kräften aus
afghanistan ist die rettungsaktion läuft
der noch weiter die bundeswehr hat
bislang rund 3000 personen ausgeflogen
aber noch ist nicht klar wie lange das
noch möglich ist denn der zeitplan der
usa sieht eigentlich vor alle truppen
bis zum 31 august abzuziehen
die diskutieren derzeit eine
verlängerung mit dem militär wir hoffen
dass das nicht nötig sein wird aber wir
werden darüber sprechen wie weit wir im
prozess gekommen sind
ein sprecher der radikal-islamischen
taliban hat einer verlängerung aber eine
absage erteilt das ist eine rote linie
wenn sie verlängern dann bedeutet das
eine verlängerung der besatzung dafür
aber gibt es keine notwendigkeit
wenn sie bleiben wird dass eine reaktion
provozieren
laut bundesregierung wird auch ein
ziviler weiterbetrieb des flughafens
kabul für evakuierungsflüge diskutiert
morgen will sich ein virtueller g7
gipfel mit der situation in afghanistan
befassen
unsere reporterin katrin eigendorf ist
im nachbarland usbekistan in der
hauptstadt taschkent am flughafen dort
landen die bundeswehr maschinen mit den
menschen aus kappel katrin wie
willkommen sind die ausgeflogenen und
die bundeswehr in usbekistan
sie sind hier gar nicht gekommen für
usbekistan ist das ein geschäft die usb
tische regierung hat das im land
terminal ihres wichtigsten flughafen es
hier in taschkent an die bundeswehr
vermietet das hier ist das wichtige
drehkreuz für die evakuierungsflüge aber
man möchte diese afghanischen boards
kräfte und auch die deutschen die hier
weiter transportiert werden hier nicht
lange haben man möchte dass diese flüge
schnell abgewickelt werden wir dürfen
auch als deutsches kamerateam gar nicht
auf den flughafen die regierung in
taschkent möchte sich mit den taliban
gut stehen und sie sind hier im prinzip
auch als flüchtlinge nicht willkommen
aber wenn man diese evakuierungsflüge
fortsetzen will dann wird man ganz
sicherlich auch mit der russischen
regierung darüber verhandeln müssen ob
das noch längerfristig weiter so geht
vielen dank für diese einschätzung aus
taschkent katrin eigendorf
nächstes thema jetzt corona bisher galt
der inzidenz wert 50 als wichtige
richtschnur von corona schutzmaßnahmen
das könnte sich aber bald ändern
schauen wir auf die karte in einigen
bundesländern ist die marke 50 schon
deutlich gerissen hier rot ausgezeichnet
besonders im westen dunkelrot bedeutet
eine inzidenz über 100 in einigen
kreisen von nordrhein-westfalen
leverkusen zum beispiel 205,8 neue
maßstab könnte künftig unter anderem die
lage in den krankenhäusern seien also
die zahl von kogit patienten in kliniken
karl hinterleitner
ab heute gilt in ganz deutschland 3g nur
geimpfte genesene oder getestete habe
noch zutritt zu geschäften wie zum
beispiel diesen münchner friseursalon
die regel bringt zwar neuen aufwand für
inhaber und kunden dafür aber auch mehr
sicherheit die besitzerin hat damit kein
problem
idealerweise wird es ein leben geben
indem vielleicht jeder geimpft ist und
wir auch ohne diese ganzen
vorkehrungen weiterarbeiten können aber
wenn es so weiter gehen muss dann geht
so weiter und wir sind damit cool und
darauf eingestellt
während sich menschen wie julia
hannappel in münchen auf immer neue
regeln der bundespolitik einstellen
müssen nimmt die in berlin heute einen
richtungswechsel vor für den
bundesgesundheitsminister hat die
inzidenz als entscheidende bezugsgröße
in der pandemie ausgedient die galt für
eine ungeimpfte bevölkerung wir haben
mittlerweile ja auch viele menschen die
sich haben impfen lassen und deswegen
ist mein vorschlag jetzt auch diesen
maßstab diese 50er incident aus dem
gesetz zügig zu streichen der neue
parameter ist dann die hospitalisierung
heißt also die kogit 19 patienten die
ins krankenhaus aufgenommen werden zur
behandlung und noch eine klare botschaft
kommt heute aus berlin für doppelt
geimpfte und genesene wird es keine
weiteren auflagen geben
ich denke man kann den geimpften sagen
dass sich für sie auch wenn jetzt die
zahlen weiter ansteigen nichts ändern
wird und das gilt auch für die genesenen
sie müssen jetzt nicht mit neuen
einschränkungen rechnen nach langen
diskussionen soll das bundeskabinett die
neuregelung nun bald beschließen wann
genau sie in kraft tritt ist noch offen
fragen wir theo koll in berlin warum ist
die bundesregierung so zögerlich wenn es
darum geht neue corona maßstäbe
festzulegen ja es ist ja so gar nicht
nur die bundesregierung sondern es war
die gesamte letzte
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz die sich
davor gedrückt hat neue maßstäbe zu
beschließen denn wer die festlegte muss
ja dann auch sagen was aus den neuen
richtwerten folgt und mit den möglichen
einschränkungen wollte sich
offensichtlich niemand politisch
wirklich belasten schon gar nicht in
wahlkampfzeit mittlerweile zeigt sich
aber sehr deutlich dass eine hohe
inzidenz angesichts von fast 60 prozent
vollständig geimpften nicht mehr zu den
bisherigen hohen hospitalisierung raten
für kurz gesagt die neuen infizierten
sind ja jünger müssen weniger oft ins
krankenhaus insofern macht es jetzt
durchaus sinn die belastung des
gesundheitssystems stärker zum maßstab
zu machen
der dafür nötige gesetzgebungsprozess so
haben wir hier gehört heute könnte schon
übermorgen beginnen danke nach berlin
theo koll
vergessene der pandemie so nennt sie der
sozialverband vdk die mehr als drei
millionen pflegebedürftigen die zu hause
versorgt werden und ihre angehörigen die
diese pflege leisten im shutdown hätten
zwei drittel von ihnen unter angst und
isolation gelitten so eine studie doch
mehr geld für die ambulante pflege habe
es nicht gegeben kritisierte vdk und
will dies nun vor gericht erstreiten
carsten behrendt
mittlerweile besucht edeltraud geister
ihren demenzkranken mann im pflegeheim
die pflege zu hause konnte sie einfach
nicht mehr stemmen in der korona zeit
keine seniorentreffs keine ausflüge kaum
noch therapie besucher die krankheit
wurde schlimmer und die beiden saßen
allein in ihrer kleinen wohnung eine
dauerbelastung die freigeister selbst
depressiv gemacht hat ich persönlich war
sehr oft wütend
auf gott und die welt also
natürlich auf ihn auch und das war dann
so dass ich gedacht habe jetzt
gehe ich überhaupt nicht mehr raus die
meisten der zu hause gepflegten und ihre
angehörigen empfinden die korona zeit
als belastung so der sozialverband vdk
heute in berlin zwei drittel der
betroffenen litten unter ängsten und
einsamkeit der vdk spricht in seiner
pflege studie von den vergessenen der
pandemie
die pflegebedürftigen und ihre
angehörigen sind überhaupt nicht im
politischen fokus es ging immer um
pflegeheime um die einrichtungen wenn
man weiß dass 80 prozent der menschen zu
hause gepflegt werden sind die
pflegebedürftigen zu hause eine große
und super wichtige gruppe und wir
fordern dass die bessere unterstützung
bekommen der sozialverband will
juristisch gegen die bundesregierung
vorgehen weil angekündigten erhöhungen
von ambulanten pflegeleistungen
ausgeblieben seien ein lichtblick in der
studie die mehrheit der befragten ist
zuversichtlich dass sie die pandemie
gemeinsam gut übersteht
schon seit monaten läuft die
impfkampagne in den usa mit mehr als 200
millionen dosen kam dabei am häufigsten
der impfstoff von bayern tech pfizer zum
einsatz bislang allerdings nur mit einer
notfall zulassung das ist nun anders die
us farmer kontrollbehörde erteilte eine
vollständige zulassung die erste
weltweit für das aktien die usa hoffen
dass sich nun noch mehr leute impfen
lassen
wieder steht ein großteil der züge in
deutschland still seit letzter nacht
streikt die gdl auch im personenverkehr
mit einer corona premier wollte die
deutsche bahn die lokführer gewerkschaft
zurück an den verhandlungstisch bringen
die fand das angebot aber nicht konkret
genug
die folge im fernverkehr fallen laut ban
rund 70 prozent aller züge aus im
regionalverkehr etwa 60 noch bis
mittwoch brauchen reisende viel geduld
martin ließen berichtet
nicht so voll wie sonst aber auch nicht
menschenleer in hamburg an deutschlands
verkehrsreichsten bahnhof ist das ganz
große chaos ausgeblieben trotz
lokführerstreik hat die bahn mit ihren
notfallplan einen teil der züge auf die
strecke gebracht kritik gab es von
reisenden für beide konfliktparteien ich
bin ein befürworter von streiks von
arbeitskämpfen aber was die gdl dort
momentan macht habe ich kein verständnis
man muss halt auch
gucken dass das die leute irgendwie auch
geld in der tasche haben und beide
seiten müssen müssen aufeinander zugehen
seit zwei uhr nachts streikt die
lokführergewerkschaft sie hatte das
gestrige angebot einer corona prämie
durch die bahn als unzureichend
abgelehnt und legte heute nach wir
erwarten dass das management
schlussendlich begreift dass die eigenen
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter an der
stelle die rote karte gezeigt haben und
von daher brauchen wir ganz klar und
deutlich der nächste streik hat länger
und er wird auch im netz ev sein wie
verhärtet die fronten sind zeigt auch
die reaktion der arbeitgeber
ungeachtet der korona pandemie
richtet die gdl-spitze schaden an und
rücksicht auf die fahrgäste ohne
rücksicht auf die ein großteil unserer
beschäftigten und um rücksicht auf das
unternehmen db das ist verantwortungslos
noch bis mindestens mittwoch müssen sich
reisende auf deutliche einschränkungen
einstellen weitere streiks könnten bald
folgen
der 23 august 1946 das war der tag an
dem mit einem federstrich und einem
bindestrich bundesdeutsche geschichte
geschrieben wurde
die britische besatzungsmacht fügte
heute vor 75 jahren den nördlichen teil
der preußischen rheinprovinz mit der
provinz westfalen zusammen das neue land
hieß nordrhein-westfalen und hatte ein
herz aus kohle und stahl das ruhrgebiet
heute hat nordrhein-westfalen 17,9
millionen einwohner und liegt auch mit
seiner wirtschaftsleistung von rund 700
milliarden euro bundesweit vorn dort
farbe berichtet
eine geburtstagsparty natürlich mit
britischen klängen nordrhein westfalen
feiert mit prominenten gästen ein
festakt in schweren zeiten die pandemie
die flut nrw packe an sagt der
ministerpräsident
land das sich durch seine offenheit
direktheit und vielfalt auszeichnet ein
land das den zusammenhalt lebt dass es
diesen zusammenhalt gibt das haben wir
zuletzt nach der großen flutkatastrophe
im juli gesehen heute vor 75 jahren
starteten die bringen ihre sogenannte
operation marriage ein verwaltungsakt
als geburtsstunde des neuen bundeslandes
nordrhein westfalen
ohne bedeutet brennende hochöfen
rauchende schlote
ankurbelung von wirtschaft und industrie
die kumpel im revier sorgen für das
nachkriegs wunder bald kommen auch die
gastarbeiter doch dem aufstieg folgt der
lange abschied zechensterben stahlkrise
auch die braunkohle steht vor dem aus
die energiewende ist da strukturwandel
als dauerzustand
wirtschaft stark bleibt nordrhein-
westfalen trotzdem und lebenswert
ohnehin
lustige menschen der karneval
rheinland und westfalen kölsch und
currywurst nrw mit vielen facetten und
75 jahren geschichte
unwetter haben teile des
us-amerikanischen ostens schwer
verwüstet allein im bundesstaat
tennessee gab es nach einem sturz wegen
21 tote es werden noch weitere menschen
vermisst nach dem abschluss der
wassermassen werden immer mehr schäden
sichtbar ganze häuser wurden von den
fluten weggespült parallel macht der
tropensturm lee vor allem rund um
metropolen wie new york probleme verlief
aber glimpflicher als befürchtet
morgen starten die paralympics in tokio
eigentlich ein großes fest für alle
beteiligten wäre da nicht corona seit
beginn der olympischen spiele hat sich
die zahl der neuinfektionen in tokio
nahezu verdreifacht dem
gesundheitssystem droht die überlastung
die wettkämpfe finden ohne zuschauer
statt stephanie schöneborn
das paralympische dorf in tokio die
athleten abgeschottet es werden spiele
zwischen hoffen auf medaillen und der
angst vor corona wir geben jeden morgen
unsere tests ab wir müssen unsere
temperatur täglich
und daher fühlen wir uns sicher wir
haben jetzt auch gar keinen kontakt groß
zu anderen teams
in der corona klinik in kawasaki im
nachbarort tokios kommen jeden tag neue
cupid patienten an die intensivstation
ist voll sie wissen nicht mehr wohin mit
den schwer erkrankten die situation sei
katastrophal
wenig künstlich beatmet werden muss kann
nicht mehr auf dieser station bleiben
die delta variante wütet in japan vor
allem ungeimpfte erkrankten schwer die
meisten krankenhäuser sind am limit
bis zu beginn der olympischen spiele
haben wir auch noch patienten aus tokio
aufnehmen können aber seit dem 10 august
steigen die zahlen einfach immer weiter
mit den spielen stiegen die
infektionszahlen auf bis zu 22.000
täglich inzwischen haben sich vier
athleten infiziert mindestens 140
personen im paralympischen umfeld und
morgen findet die eröffnungsfeier statt
zum sport und zu einem der sich bestimmt
gern an tokio erinnert olympiasieger
alexander grimm hat er wieder ein
turnier gewonnen ja und zwar das
hochkarätige tennis event in cincinatti
eine woche vor beginn der us open zeigt
deutschlands bester tennisspieler sein
ganzes können beim 6 2 6 2 3
schnelldurchgang sie gegen den russen
andrejew
in der form seines lebens auf der
weltrangliste mittlerweile auf position
vier favoriten die bevorstehenden us
open gegen seinen freund andré hublift
zverev sein greift das spiel auch im
angriff mittlerweile aus einem guss dass
seine rückhand ihresgleichen sucht
beweist er immer wieder
in nur 58 minuten gewinnt er 6 2 und 6 2
3 und ist nach boris becker der zweite
deutsche der in cincinatti gewinnt
die deutschen volleyballerinnen haben
bei der em dank einer starken
kämpferischen leistung den zweiten sieg
im dritten spiel eingefahren und stehen
nach dem erfolg über gastgeber bulgarien
so gut wie sicher im achtelfinale
eklat im französischen derby zwischen
nizza und marseille nachdem ein
gästespieler als reaktion eine
plastikflasche zurück in richtung heim
publikum geworfen hat kommt es zu
schweren ausschreitungen
erst flogen wurfgeschosse dann die
fäuste spieler von olympique marseille
mussten nach der 75 minute nicht mehr
ihr tor sondern sich selbst verteidigen
gewaltbereite anhänger aus nizza stürmt
und dem platz es wurde entschieden das
spiel abzubrechen weil die sicherheit
der spieler nicht gewährleistet war die
staatsanwaltschaft hat ermittlungen
eingeleitet frankreichs regierung
fordert sanktionen
die liga lebt die mannschaften vor am
ende gingen nur verlierer vom platz
bayern münchen hat wie erwartet den
vertrag mit fußball nationalspieler
josué vorzeitig um zwei jahre verlängert
der 26-jährige mittelfeldspieler bleibt
damit bis 2025 beim fcb ja und gestern
abend zeigten er gabriel und co immer
wieder großen kampfgeist nach der 2 0
führung der bayern gegen köln zwei
gegentreffer ja und dann doch noch ein
hart erkämpfter 3 2 sieg sarah stähli
ist dass der einer spannenden zweiten
halbzeit das i-tüpfelchen verpasst die
bayern jubeln und die fans schwärmen
lässt ob eines gewaltigen traumtors in
der 1 nach 2 0 führung für die bayern im
heimischen stadion zeigt der fc
spielfreude klasse und kampfeswillen
hectors feine flanke verwertet modells
zum anschlusstreffer auch der sehenswert
der ausgleich von gut innerhalb von 120
sekunden
doch letztlich beschert sabri trainer
nagelsmann und in bayern den ersten liga
erfolg
alle spiele alle tore des zweiten
spieltags bei sportstudio und in der
zdf- heute hab ich danke sehr herzlich
das war es dann wohl mit dem sommer sagt
gleich katja hornuf hochsommerhitze ist
nicht mehr zu erwarten wohl aber
sonnenschein claus kleber freut sich auf
sie im heute journal um viertel vor zehn
wir danken für ihr interesse wünschen
ihnen noch einen schönen montagabend
alles gute und freuen uns wenn sie
morgen wieder dabei sind
[Musik]
guten abend die zeichen stehen auf
herbst mit dem hochsommer ist es jetzt
wirklich vorbei dieses tief manfred hat
viel regen gebracht in sachsen anhalt in
sachsen aber auch im südlichen
brandenburg und in thüringen
es zieht jetzt langsam weiter nach osten
und deswegen wird es von norden immer
klarer heute nacht also klarer
sternenhimmel von der ostseeküste bis
zur mosel in der oberlausitz aber auch
in bayern fällt dagegen noch regen und
an der nordseeküste und unter den
regenwolken bleibt es vergleichsweise
mild mit 14 bis 10 grad sonst aber gibt
es zum teil schon einstellige nach
temperaturen hier von nordfriesland bis
zur eifel sinken die werte auf 9 bis 7
grad und morgen erwarten uns dann 19 bis
23 grad in bayern allerdings bleibt es
bei 14 bis 17 grad deutlich kälter denn
dort hat sich die sonne morgen wirklich
schwer und anfänglich fällt auch noch
regen sonst hat das ein freundlicher
dienstag bei nordostwind und am
freundlichsten wird's wohl hier im
westen deutschlands in den nächsten
tagen wird es wechselhafter werden von
norden kommen nämlich neue regenwolken
heran und es wird auch von tag zu tag
wieder am freitag liegen dann die
höchsttemperatur nur noch bei 14 bis 19
grad guten abend